[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com according to the latest ABC
news/washington post poll Donald Trump's
approval rating down a 36 percent this
is a historic low for all 70 years of
presidential approval polling at the
six-month mark of a presidency of which
we are three days shy today here are the
results from this particular ABC
news/washington post poll if you don't
believe this poll only and we'll keep
this up for people to check out Gallup
has it within the same margin of error
as these results 38% approval for Trump
versus 36% statistically effectively the
same Trump behind only Ford who had a 39
percent approval rating at the six-month
mark of his presidency so we were
wondering how the growing Russia scandal
would affect Donald Trump's approval the
views of the American people on the
Russia scandal are pretty interesting
63% of Americans almost two-thirds
believed that that meeting that Donald
Trump jr. had with the Russian lawyer in
Trump Tower was inappropriate 60 percent
believe that Russia tried to influence
the campaign this is low and Trump's
approval has already been down to 36
percent before and this was undeniably
on a totally inappropriate meeting with
the Russian lawyer Russia undeniably
tried to interfere in the election we
have written evidence of that now and as
more people find out I can only assume
that it's at minimum not going to help
Donald Trump's approval rating and it
will likely hurt it the health care
proposal to repeal and replace Obamacare
that's not helping by a two-to-one
margin Americans prefer Obamacare which
we have now to the latest version of the
American Hal
Care Act and what Donald Trump's
reaction he's calling 36% 40% and he's
saying 40% is pretty good he took to
Twitter the other day over the weekend
and said quote the ABC Washington Post
poll even though almost 40% is not bad
at this time was just about the most
inaccurate poll around election time I
thought Trump went to Wharton School of
Business at the University of
Pennsylvania would they agree that 40 or
rather 36% is not bad at any point I
don't think so bad he has been having
some issues when it comes to math and
remember this is the president who
asserts that he would have won the
popular vote had three to five million
people not voted illegally yeah and now
he has this so-called voting election
commission going on to uphold our
integrity and he has Mike Pence and Kris
Kobach working hard on that but you'd
have to imagine that if there was so
many people voting illegally and voting
for his opponent that his job approval
numbers would be so much higher now
right because the election results where
he lost the popular vote by 3 million
would not reflect the will of the people
who really really liked the job he's
doing no no indication of that
whatsoever and the really sad situation
is that 36% of the country still
approves if the job Donald Trump is
doing that means if you go to three
random people obviously depends on where
in the country you are but in total
victory random people from our country
statistically one of those people is
going to say I approve of the job that
Donald Trump is doing and the obvious
question is what exactly is it that you
approve of and how does this affect his
ability to govern that is the key sort
of political question an unpopular
president means number one fewer people
feel the need to make a deal with him or
help him if he stays at 36% or drops it
becomes more and more likely that
Republicans will actually turn on him
for their own self-preservation and
we're starting to see more and more of
that happen in what other job would you
have a 36 percent approval rating or
maybe it would be a customer
satisfaction rating in a job and spend
22
of your time playing golf and be allowed
to keep your job not too many jobs would
let you get away with that we are
learning more about this meeting that
Donald Trump jr. had with the Russian
lawyer Natalia vessel mitts kaya in
Trump Tower last June of 2016 this was
the first definitive proof of Russian
interference in the election we have
written evidence now Donald Trump jr.
has been painting it as a total waste of
time
with nothing of value coming from it
that was such a waste of time that he
didn't even bother telling Donald Trump
senior about it we have now learned that
there were even more people in the
meeting than originally reported we knew
about the lawyer herself right Netanya
Natalia vessel mitts kaya
and of course Donald Trump jr. was there
Jared Kushner was there and Paul
Manafort was there that was four people
we've now learned and this is just
stunning that a Russian American
lobbyist named Renaud Ahmed chin was
also in the meeting and he is known for
opposition research exactly what the
meeting and Trump Tower purported to be
about if you wanted to collude with
Russia to smear a political opponent
Renata och mitchen is sort of like the
first person you'd meet with because
this is his area of expertise and he was
not the only other person in the room he
gets us to five people in the room but
we've confirmed the presence of Rob
Goldstone the publicist who arranged the
meeting to begin with that gets us to
six people in the room we've learned
that a translator a Russian translator
was in the room that gets us to seven as
well as a representative of the Russian
family who asked for the meeting to set
up that gets us to eight people minimum
this is a lot of people in the room pad
for a 20-minute waste of time that was
so not memorable that Trump jr. Kushner
and Paul Manafort all initially forgot
to disclose it quite a team of people in
there for something that made no
difference and remember how Donald Trump
juniors story it changed four or five
times when more information came out
from New York Times well after all of
that Trump jr. went on Sean Hannity show
it should have been a safe space for him
door and he said that was it that we
weren't going to learn anymore
about this meeting turns out in the next
24 hours we find there's more people in
that room yeah but I'm sure now we have
the full story right because even though
there were like four or five instances
where the truth wasn't told about this
meeting now they're no longer telling
any lies and they're being fully upfront
about everything that happened it's
almost like his credibility has been
destroyed on this day I know uh that
what we're noticing is he's willing to
be super upfront about whatever details
have or are about to be leaked by the
New York Times or Washington Post
you get super honest and transparent as
soon as you learned that's going to
happen uh this is gone beyond the shock
and surprised at the depths of the
intent to collude this is now under the
umbrella of major national security
concern we have an administration that
could be completely compromised to
Russia and more sensitive to the desires
of a foreign power than they are to the
actual needs of the American people we
haven't heard much from Kellyanne Conway
in the national media
after that pathetic embarrassment of the
so-called bowling-green massacre that of
course never happened and doesn't exist
that she mentioned on TV she mentioned
that and then basically stops doing
national media I don't know if she's
been in timeout long enough that now
she's out of it or if things are just
getting so desperate for the Trump
administration that they figured hey
let's put her back on TV which she
appeared on a number of programs over
the weekend including on Fox News to
talk about the growing Trump Russia
scandal let's start with her appearance
on Fox and Friends she went on Fox &
Friends to talk about how it's just no
big deal that Donald from jr. met with a
Russian lawyer and a Russian lobbyist
and blah blah blah blah blah and I want
to prepare you for what we're about to
see in here she is about to move the
goal posts and use projection and blame
Hillary to try to distract from what's
going on but she moves the goal posts
herself by accusing others of having
moved the goalposts just sit down get
the kids out of the room because this is
really really bad we don't want to
listen I'd show them Janet Jackson's
breasts ten times before I showed them
the
atrocity that I'm about to show I'm not
even going to watch at yeah Pat you
Pat's leaving the room himself
here's clip number one of Kellyanne
Conway's immediate implosion over the
weekend well even the goalposts have
been moved
I mean we were promised systemic hard
evidence of systemic sustained furtive
collusion that not only interfered with
our election process but indeed dictated
the electoral outcome and one of the
only people who says that seriously
these days is still Hillary Clinton and
he believes it we know why she lost it's
obvious and and frankly you know when I
was campaign manager in those last
several months I you know when I needed
negative information about Hillary
Clinton I didn't have to go very far I
looked at influitive Clinton yeah so
listen they've been swearing up and down
that they never met with Russians they
never talked to Russians Russians didn't
help him with the campaign in any way
that's now undeniable they've moved the
goalposts to the collusion wasn't
illegal and instead she says that it's
others who are moving the goalposts then
she gets asked a specific question by
the bumbling Steve Doocy and she goes
back to blame Hillary Clinton but Kelly
yeah I'll call you up all the time and
say hey I got some dirt on her and would
you take a meeting with them no the
president said yesterday that kind of
occurrence happen all the time
well it does but in the case of Hillary
Clinton it was fantasy yeah let's talk
again about Hillary Clinton now contrast
this with what Kellyanne Conway herself
had to say in January listen to how
definitive she was here
did anyone involved in the Trump
campaign have any contact with Russians
trying to meddle with the election
absolutely not and I discussed that with
the president-elect just last night
those conversations never happen I hear
people saying it like it's a fact vision
that is just not only inaccurate is the
president aware it does undermine our
democracy
nobody was involved there was no contact
we now have proof in writing so this is
bad enough but if you can believe it it
gets even worse she then went on ABC's
Good Morning America and claimed with a
straight face that the real problem here
is
James commis leaking of information
that's the problem according to
Kellyanne Kellyanne what we have to go
the information was sought from the
campaign and those denials were allowed
to stand for many months that's the
bottom line
thanks very much you're done I wasn't in
the meeting I was in the meeting but
people amended their disclosure forms
and I think the big bombshell this
morning is Jim call me disclosing
confidential information conversations
you have with the president I stated
quote private memos that's something
Americans should release oh yeah focus
on that
these are Liars of the highest order
this is shameless dishonestly and at
this point it's indicative of panic and
a question for a lawyer would be at what
point if any legally speaking do
Kellyanne Conway's persistent public
lies become part of the cover-up would
you be willing to have a serious
conversation with Kellyanne Conway cos I
don't think I would be able to learn
available projection shifting the
goalposts I mean there's no intellectual
honesty there and we can't even agree on
what the facts are because she has
alternative fact I would have a serious
conversation with her if she were
capable of doing that and less
substantive but just as wacky here is
Kellyanne Conway doing rhyming while
holding signs up on Fox News I just want
to review in case you run out of time
and this is how you see it so far this
is to help all the people at home what's
the conclusion
collusion no we don't have that yet I
see illusion and delusion so just over
clear everyone forwards conclusion
collusion no illusion delusion yes I
just thought we'd have some fun with
words so Sesame's Grover where is the
day perhaps yeah when the indictments
come in I hope that she's going to spend
her time on something other than picture
sign of words on how to position
whatever you would even call this
nonsense this is insane she was making
it easy for the fox news audience to
understand it yes she had to speak to
the lowest common denominator
folks what is going on here I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show follow me
there the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Trevor Hill Trevor thank you for
supporting our program we our viewer and
listener-supported media you can go to
david pakman.com slash membership to
sign up today the coupon code is
available to you for a major big league
discount off of membership the coupon
code is I voted 17 you can also make a
pledge of as little as one dollar a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show that's p80 r e n.com slash david
pakman show approaching 1800 patrons and
of course if you ever shop on amazon go
to david pakman.com slash amazon before
you shop and then everything you buy
will send us a little kickback alright
we've got more sponsored memberships to
give away here you'll remember that two
weeks ago a user who goes only by the
name gr sponsored six free memberships
for people who could come up with clever
incoherent rants in the style of this
particular user last week we gave away
for membership sponsored by jennifer
karein and the theme there was patriotic
progressivism or i guess really
progressive patriotism either one better
way to say it either way either way it's
fine with me I now have a viewer
Marshall brats who is getting in on the
action
and I think this is a good option if you
don't feel like having to do anything
for your membership if you don't want to
have to write an incoherent rant or a
progressive patriotic letter this is a
slightly different setup that it that I
think you're going to like Marshall is
sponsoring half of 30 memberships okay
he's a huge fan of the sports and
politics TV series known as 30 for 30
so he's sponsoring $30 towards 30
memberships right he is paying half of
30 memberships you pay the other half
and these are going to be first-come
first-served if you want a half
membership martial brats has already
prepaid for half of 30 memberships if
you want to pay for the other half and
you can lock in that half price rate for
as long as you want email me through the
contact form at david pakman.com the
subject make it whatever free membership
marshals memberships membership get
conned with whatever right and say I
want one of those half-price memberships
and the first 30 people to email me will
be sent to coupon code and that will be
that and just so everybody knows Pat now
has several hundred thousand memberships
he is not allowed to participate in this
thing I was going to resell them on the
black market you know this is a bit
listen you've got enough stuff going on
with the Keurig okay so last thing we
need is you of reselling memberships on
the black market
Pat is not allowed to participate so
thirty non current members it's for new
members that's the one stipulation email
me Marshall brats has paid for half of
your membership you pay for the other
half david pakman.com click on contact
us these go quickly these can go quite
quickly I like this because there's a
number of way to allocate goods and
services you want do it by merit or by
seniority or by Meade or by Z this is
first come first serve this is first
come first served absolutely so I will
update you tomorrow as to whether there
are any of those remaining but let's do
it get in touch with me get one of those
half-price memberships foxnews has been
going out of its way to avoid telling
the truth about trump russia and out of
its way to avoid visitors to its website
from even being allowed to post the
truth about donald trump juniors meeting
with that russian lawyer and russian
lobbyist there was a sentence this is
obviously very high-level and sensitive
information but as part of russia and
its government support for mr. trump
that was a line from one of the emails
that Donald Trump jr. was involved in
and that sentence was blocked from Fox
News's web site they set up some kind of
an auto filter that would remove that
line from its comment section and they
conveniently are not including that part
of the email in articles about this the
filter was first discovered by a Reddit
user who goes by the name eff all Nazis
which is an interesting username in and
of its
and the filter was set up not just on
stories about the Trump Russia meeting
but even on stories that have nothing to
do with that whatsoever so that's number
one Fox News by and large going out of
its way to censor the truth about Trump
Russia so there's how webley's on this
dot dot dot between that no matter how
they wrote it the autofilter' was
updated to pick it up people tried to
reword it slightly or an ellipses or
whatever not allowed on the Fox News
website however there are kind of
shockingly some people on Fox News at
least trying to tell the truth about
what's going on with Trump Russia which
is that this is a major scandal of epic
and historic deception I'm going to play
this clip for you this is Shepard Smith
talking to Chris Wallace and they were
sort of making an effort to just be
upfront about the level of deception
that was going on take a look at this
we've been told of a variety of stories
we've gotten and who knows if we're if
we've gotten to the end of the story we
already have to be at night now in your
emails and now that we have it because
there's news breaking at this moment
career okay Fox News can now confirm
knew more Donald Trump jr. Jared Kushner
Paul Manafort the lawyer from Russia the
interpreter this new guy we found out
about today and a mystery person John
Roberts confirms there was an eighth
person in that meeting we don't know
there may have been more but there was
an eighth Jared Kushner filled out his
form
I think it's an f-86 saying who he'd met
with and what he'd done very important
stuff you go to prison for messing it up
you know intentionally he went back and
added 100 names in places none of these
people made it is still not clear we're
still not clean on this Chris it's if
there's nothing there and that's what
they tell us they tell us there's
nothing to this and nothing came of it
there's a nothing burger it wasn't even
memorable didn't write it down didn't
tell you about it because it wasn't
anything so I didn't even remember it
with a Russian interpreter in the room
at Trump Tower if all of that why all
these lies
I is it lie after lie after lie if you
clean come on clean you know my
grandmother used to say when first we
practice to Oh
what a tangled web we weave when first
we practice to deceive the deception
chris is is mind boggling and there are
still people who out there who believe
we're making it up and one day they're
going to realize we're not and look
around and go where are we and why are
we getting told all these lies you know
I don't know what to say I think that
that there's a lot of that of truth to
everything that you've said the rest of
the network is still in blame Hillary
for everything mode and even better
blame Obama if you can Brit Hume has
shifted from there was no collusion - if
there was collusion it wouldn't be
illegal anyway so who cares but at least
for now chef Smith and Chris Wallace are
saying what they think right wingers on
Twitter immediately calling for their
firing and/or resignations Kushner could
be led away in handcuffs by the feds and
Fox News would come out with breaking
bombshell Hillary did something kind of
similar a few years ago or breaking
Obama didn't physically stop Trump from
meeting with Russians so he's really the
guy to blame but the truth is it's
getting pretty unavoidable at this point
some common sense is bound to seep
through even on Fox News you know this
was just about the meeting I think they
would have a case to be made to defend
the White House here they could go to
the talking points of well collusion is
not a crime they didn't get any valuable
information out of that meeting and
while those are easily debunked they
could still make that case yeah but the
lies are what makes this indefensible
and I think you know some people with a
little bit of intellectual honesty like
chef Smith and like Chris Wallace
they're able to fess up to that I really
hope chef Smith doesn't accidentally
stabbed himself in the back ten times I
really hope he doesn't because it is
this level of honesty is not looked upon
favorably by Fox News by the Fox News
audience and by any players who want to
cover up what is now in in writing
evidence of collusion between Russia and
the Trump campaign if you believe that
time goes in a forward sequence at least
in our universe or within our
understanding of our universe then
there's a little problem with the timing
of when Donald Trump's June Donald Trump
juniors
or started getting paid Donald Trump jr.
now has a lawyer who's been saying all
sorts of wacky and zany things in
defense of his client around his meeting
with the Russian lawyer and the Russian
lobbyists and Trump Tower this is a
meeting that we now know he attended the
Jared Kushner and Paul Mann afford and a
translator and a member of some family
that wanted to set it up and Rob
Goldstone it was a party this is a major
major a group of people that was in this
meeting and this is now an individual in
Donald Trump jr. who's being represented
by the Law Offices of åland Theodore
Foss great that's who's representing him
the problem around the timing is that
Donald Trump's re-election campaign
started paying this attorney for his
work representing Donald Trump jr. two
weeks before the recent scandal around
this meeting so there's actually four
problems that I've identified with this
or red flags you tell me which is the
worst Pat number one it's harder to
believe that this meeting was a total
non-story
if you hired a guy to defend Trump jr.
two weeks the scandal broke unless he
was hired for some other issue related
to Trump Russia which would also be bad
since Trump jr. wasn't even publicly at
the center of that two weeks ago that's
problem number one problem number two
it's odd that the re-election campaign
of Trump is making these payments our
donors aware when they donate to the
campaign for Donald Trump's reelection
that the money at least part of it is
being used not to help Donald Trump's
reelection chances but for lawyers for
Trump's kid who doesn't even have an
official role in the administration
number three this is an attorney Alan
Theodore Foss who specializes in
white-collar criminal defense not
political law not election law and that
circles back to the question of why was
he hired two weeks before this scandal
broke unless there's way more
potentially criminal activity that he's
representing Donald Trump jr. about and
number four what message does this send
to other White House staffers who were
told you may want to lawyer up but we're
not paying for it you're on your own but
Trump's son who's not even part of the
administration is getting a lawyer paid
for by the re-election
committee of Donald Trump which is the
headline Alan future Fox is connected to
Mafia family Oh young New York or he's
represented three or four mafia
organized crime families yep
and you know I get it you're a lawyer
you have to pick some specialty that's
your line of work you can't really get
them at Adam for that it's unclear what
a special T is telling that he's now
representing the Trump family and all of
that
absolutely and yeah I don't know what
the big headline is right it could be
that everyone involved
knew that this was a major issue long
before it went public it could be that
Trump jr. could be facing criminal
charges it could be the defrauding of
re-election donors to Trump's
re-election campaign who are being
targeted by email or requesting donate
to Trump's reelection to help fight fake
news and all this other garbage and then
the money is going for a lawyer for Don
Jr and it also could be the immorality
of wrapping up who knows how many White
House staffers in the scandal and then
leaving them to pay for their own
lawyers while your own donors are
covering expensive lawyers for your kids
and by the way there's one other scandal
brewing here Lachlan Marquis is the
White House reporter for The Daily Beast
he got his hands on a tax document which
I'll put up on the screen for you which
shows a payment to the Trump corporation
for ninety thousand dollars on the last
day of June they were paid for legal
consulting breaking news the Trump
Organization is not a law firm
so if Trump's reelection campaign has
cut a ninety thousand dollar check to
Trump's business for legal consulting
that means one of two things
it's either straight-up money laundering
they're saying it's for legal consulting
and it's not or they are giving 90 grand
to the Trump organization so that the
Trump Organization can then give that 90
grand to a lawyer for legal services
which is another form of money
laundering meaning you're raising money
under the pretext of being for Trump's
re-election and then it is being given
to the Trump Organization to pay for
lawyers for things that have nothing to
do with re-election I can only hope that
Robert Muller can parse all of this and
determine to quote Donald Trump what the
hell is going on
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum David Patrick ons class
RGGI please the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to welcome
back to the program up by audience
requests dr. Aubrey de Grey the chief
science officer of the Sens Research
Foundation which is a biomedical
research charity that develops new
therapies to combat aging so let's start
there I first became aware of your work
back in 2005 when you were featured in
60 minutes and we've spoken about the
broad and narrower focus of your work a
number of times how would you
characterize the progress that's been
made since that 60 minutes piece in 2005
in the areas you work on it's been
pretty good I mean for anyone I guess
working at the cutting edge of any
pioneering technology there's always a
kind of you know double edge to it you
always have you know pride about how
much progress has been made but at the
center and you always wish it could have
been even more but yeah I mean took on
okay the what the Sens Research
Foundation has done in the past decade
has really you know we've broken through
a number of really formidable barriers
that were completely you know stalling
research in various areas so that now
even the most difficult areas of sense
are seeing great rapid progress and
that's enormously heartening also one
thing that really makes a huge impact
for us and we hope will continue to do
so is that a number of our projects over
the past couple of years especially
have reached a sufficient level of
brutal concept that we've been able to
spin them out into startup companies in
one way or another and of course there's
a huge number of people out there who
are you know visionary and you know they
want to invest in high-risk high-reward
activities but they don't want to
generate so they have been difficult for
us to gain access to as a non-profit but
now that we can offer true investment
opportunities that opens up a whole new
source of funding so yeah I think things
definitely moving forward and of course
it also applies to work that other
people have been doing independently of
us so there are you know very well-known
things that have happened in the past
decade like the development of induced
pluripotent stem cells and CRISPR
between editing and such lag and there
are also a number of much less
well-known things which are still very
important that have allowed these big
areas to move forward so of course well
let's look at cancer for example the
whole field of cancer immunotherapy
which was really you know seeing very
little progress over 20 years until a
few years ago is now completely exploded
and everyone's working on it now and we
have close links with a number of the
most cutting-edge leading companies that
are working that even though it's not
actually resulting from our own work so
yeah I mean it once really got to be
pretty happy about where things are
standing right now the layperson might
look at for the sake of sticking with
this 2005 day just the last 12 or so
years one might look at life expectancy
in 2005 and compare it to life
expectancy for someone born in 2017 and
see that while there's been a modest
improvement it is after all sort of sort
of modest is that even a good indicator
as to the progress of the type of work
that you're doing
not remotely it's absolutely unrelated
the work that we're doing is early-stage
biomedical research which has not yet
got anywhere near even reaching clinical
trials
and of course when it does reach
clinical trials has been another forever
a long period while the tests are really
done before the thing actually reaches
the wider world will become something
that doctors can actually use and even
then we would not expect to see any
impact on the statistics that you're
talking about on the demographics of
life expectancy for quite a period after
that until the impact of these therapies
has actually been felt across the world
or across the country in terms of
widespread adoption so yeah absolutely
irrelevant it is interesting to look of
course at what is driving the increase
in life expectancy that we're seeing and
most people think that at this point the
the main driver is the same one that it
has been for the past several decades
really namely the improved prosperity
that various web that all developed
countries really have what we're able to
see a hundred years ago or there abouts
during the first half of the 20th
century the life expectancy was of
course rising pretty rapidly because we
were seeing progressively more universal
access to simple medicines that and
hygiene and so on that would prevent
early deaths in infancy or in childbirth
or whatever but at the same time is that
we were also seeing better nutrition and
it turns out that nutrition very early
in life even prenatal nutrition is a
really important contributor to lifelong
health including life expectancy of
course so there's a widespread agreement
now that this is probably the number one
contributor that people who were born
let's say 80 years ago just were on
average born in a more prosperous
environment in metal USA than people who
were born let's say ten or twenty or
thirty years earlier another bad news is
that that is probably reaching
diminishing returns now most of the the
impact of increased prosperity
that has been the driver of best wood
pretty much done by 80 years ago so what
that would predict is that over the next
10 or 20 years we probably will see a
leveling off or slowing down of the
increase in life expectancy and indeed
oh I don't know if you're familiar with
the book by Angus Deaton where he writes
about this the Nobel Prize winner Angus
Deaton he talks quite a bit about how
you know the early early 20th century
saw drastic increases in life expectancy
in more developed countries mostly as a
result of reducing infant mortality in
other words if you save people who have
many years left to live that will impact
life expectancy much more drastically
than cancer treatments that might extend
someone's life for a few years and then
in the in the second half of the 20th
century we saw that reduction in infant
mortality spread more to the developing
world and this seems to be a bit of a
ceiling we're approaching is it not so
um think of it as a kind of soft feeling
so yes the the reduction in mortality
that with early mortality caused by
infections was pretty much over by World
War two in the developed world and in
fact it's reaching a kind of ceiling
even in most of the developing world now
if you look at worldwide statistics it
turns out that overall life expectancy
across the whole world I'd together is
now something like 71 so in other words
it's less than one decade short of where
the developed world is and the largest
countries in the world are of course the
major contributors to that so we're
talking you know China India Brazil
Indonesia Pakistan Bangladesh these
countries are all motoring up and and
there's not much more to do
now the second wave of life expectancy
increase that I mentioned that's caused
by improved
early life nutrition and such like that
too is beginning to reach diminishing
returns in the developed world and I
think it's going to you know beast who
continued to be a major contributor in
the
in the India's very large countries in
the developing world for a little while
longer but yeah any any contributor to
increased longevity eventually hit
diminishing returns and you need some
new thing to do better and so of course
the new thing that's coming next but it
won't be with us but maybe 20 years from
now is the kind of work that sense
Research Foundation does the
regenerative medicine the rejuvenation
technologies that will repair the damage
with aging and keep it useful to go
through some of the different areas in
which one one could focus this type of
work you and I have spoken about a diet
of related factors we've spoken a little
bit about stem cell research you
mentioned the CRISPR project is there
one particular Avenue that you believe
has the most promise in the work you're
doing no there is not I think it's very
important to understand that even though
our approach of repairing damage
eliminates a huge majority of the
complexity of the problem that the
complexity of Aging the complexity of
metabolism and pathologies nevertheless
it's still pretty complicated so this
needs to be viewed very much as a divide
and conquer approach in which we
compartmentalize the various types of
damage or aging we classify them into a
manageable number of categories we
always talk about seven categories and
each of those categories has a
corresponding damage repair paradigm a
damage repair approach that we are
developing at elevated were developing
but the key thing to take into account
is that any one of those seven types of
damage is perfectly capable of killing
us all on schedule more or less you know
however well depicts all the other fix
so we can't it would be a very bad idea
to impose some kind of ranking of
importance we do have a ranking of
properties for ourselves in terms of
where we put our money in funding
research but that ranking is dictated by
the necessity to not have a
in other words the things that we do
prioritize are simply the things that
other people are working on more
effectively and where we would make less
of a difference and I think we
prioritize are the things that are most
neglected by other researchers where are
you currently on caloric restriction I
recently read about a study I believe it
was a 20-year or two decades study
looking at caloric restriction in
monkeys and that particular study said
its results show that there was no
longevity increase in the monkeys who
were on a calorically restricted diet
what's your sense of that study and
caloric restriction in general right so
there were actually two studies
happening in parallel both in the USA on
monkey calorie restriction and they both
reported results around the same time a
few years ago now one of them reported
no increase as you say the other one
reported us a small increase in
longevity we look more closely at the
data the two studies were not really in
contradiction to each other because the
details of how the studies were done
seem to indicate that the truth is
somewhere in between that the probably
wasn't in the public can be an increase
from lifelong calorie restriction in one
case it's very small maybe a few percent
in terms of the increase in longevity
now this to me was no surprise
whatsoever of course it's a much smaller
increase than what you see in sure to
live species if you go down the list of
calorie restriction studies in terms of
species on whom it have been tried the
next longest lived is Labradors drugs
that normally live about 11 years and
actually Purina funded a study of
calorie restriction in Labradors some
time ago in which they go roughly 10%
increasing lifespan in mice you can get
to 40 or 50 percent depending on what do
the same for rats with embedded animals
of course live a couple of years
normally if you go down the evolutionary
chain further and you look at you know
food
or nematode you can get several fold
increases if you do this kind of thing
just right and of course the same
applies in all of these species if
rather than doing calorie restriction
itself you kind of emulate calories
which can be kind of trick the body into
thinking that it had been a famine when
it isn't by manipulating the genetics
the genes of the animals or in some
cases by pharmacological means drugs
like rapamycin for example but the
reason I said it's not surprise is
because this inverse correlation that we
see where longer lived species get less
of a benefit from calorie restriction
this is something that not only have
been observed for a very long time prior
to this monkey study but also it's
predicted by evolutionary theory if we
just remember that long famines in the
wild in nature are not so frequent as
four times then that immediately
predicts that the selective advantage
the Selective pressure that a species
would experience to have machinery that
would respond to famine by shifting
metabolic priorities in a word that
extends life you know that that pressure
will be weaker in long-lived species so
it's all very much what I would have
expected and the disappointing thing is
that a large number of very
distinguished and smarts gerontologist
have basically totally ignored this for
using your denier they've basically just
slipped this look like under the carpet
and carried on studying careers cliques
and other people the whole DeGraw hello
like extensive there's no way that I
could be let's pick up our conversation
there we'll continue tomorrow with dr.
Aubrey de Grey the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
the right lightsticks a national
healthcare systems as bad bad bad
Canada's terrible the UK is a disaster
it's all bad all in defense of this
immoral for-profit employer connected
health care system that we have in the
United States the DC think tank known as
the Commonwealth Fund did a study of the
health care systems of 11 wealthy
countries and it found may be a surprise
to some of you maybe not that the
American system is the worst by multiple
measures and this includes countries
like the UK Australia Canada Germany
Sweden the UK's national health services
was the best in many categories the five
categories evaluated were access to care
equality of access for people of
different incomes administrative
efficiency how well the care process
works and how good the health outcomes
are now it's not all a panacea for these
other countries right so like for
example the UK system was first overall
but was tenth in terms of health care
outcomes but the big consistency was
that the u.s. did terribly in every
single area access to care the u.s. was
a disaster for example 44% of low-income
people in the United States have trouble
accessing care compared to only 7% of
low-income people in the UK and notably
the report says that there's been some
improvement as a result of Obamacare but
this is more evidence that Obamacare is
no incredible wonderful appending of the
healthcare status quo it's a slight
improvement or it has slowed down the
worsening of some areas of the system
but it's no massive victory and in total
in overall performance the u.s. was dead
last the leaders were as I mentioned the
UK was first followed by Australia and
the Netherlands where the US turn up at
the top of the list of countries well in
terms of how much we spend we are
leading the way and this relates to many
many issues this relates to the fact
that we have a system that seeks profit
we've got a total bureaucratic
efficiency due to the medical billing
and insurance system that we have it's a
total train wreck we spend more than
every other country on the list and we
have the worst overall health care
system how can anyone be proud of that
you know right-wingers go on and on
about how America is number one I don't
think we're number one in this category
number eleven here this should be a
point of national pride right I mean to
the right-wing Patriots wouldn't it be
nice to be able to be really proud of
how well our health care system works
instead of like how many bombs we have
or something like that or does that
point of view make me a beta male I
don't know maybe it does that I think it
would be nice to be proud of our health
care system seems like you want poor
people to survive in this country there
are people to live longer and get this
deeper perspective to have and know no
country is perfect some will point out
that a waiting times for some procedures
are longer in some of the countries on
the list
others might point out that costs might
be lower in other countries because
maybe nurses aren't paid well or
something like that there are always
problems but this study pretty nicely
sums up sort of like the net impact of
all aspects of the system and it's just
absolutely vile and disgusting and I
want to remind you I've said this before
there is something called HR 676 out
there HR 676 is a house proposal called
the expanded and improved Medicare for
all Act and it basically is single-payer
health care not in a literal sense what
it actually would do is take the
Medicare system we have which has done a
better job of holding costs not as high
lower might be a bit of a stretch but
from going as high it's a system that
works quite well in many ways the idea
would be to expand Medicare to everybody
this has been proposed a number of times
by House Democrats it basically never
has a shot at going anywhere
but it is there it is there and a lot of
people don't know about it and you can
go to who is my representative calm
figure out who does represent you in
both the Senate and the house start
making calls send faxes do whatever you
want I mean it seems like whenever we
talk about overhauling the health care
system you're going to have legislation
that's hundreds of pages long you know
it's not gonna be this simple but you're
effectively just making the age
requirement for Medicare zero and that's
a lot easier to do than to maybe pass
Obamacare or the American healthcare act
all you're doing is going into Medicare
and this is a slight oversimplification
but changing the minimum age at which
you can get Medicare it is a very
interesting proposal that is completely
dead in the water unfortunately but
still HR 676 just talk about it call
your representatives about it okay last
week we had a very special vegan dessert
tasting because it was vegan producer
Pat's birthday and as a result it really
seems to have triggered in the best way
not triggered in a negative way but
triggered in the best way a deluge of
mostly positive and of course some
negative comments about producer Pat but
the negative
there's always negative comments about
anything we do however one of Pat's
biggest admirers has left a voicemail at
two one nine to david p i don't know
that i could sum up call her Bobby's
feelings other than to say he is quite
taken with Pat take a listen to this I
thought your highest secured most famous
gave her a fan Bobby I'm so sorry that I
missed your birthday I wish I could I
wish you could have got your birthday
with me I love you more than any other
gay guy in the whole world Oh Patrick
you're so beautiful he was a wonderful
sexiest young dude I've ever seen in my
life
happy birthday Patrick I love you I want
to marry you
so I am NOT going to reject the
assertion from this caller that they are
your your biggest gay fan but I don't
think that they're your biggest
heterosexual fan because there are other
people who call in or write in and they
say I am heterosexual but I
I love Pat and you had super attractive
so I think that will take Bobby at his
word that he's your biggest gay fan
because no one else is sort of like
self-appointed themselves but I think
that there is definitely there are
definitely bigger heterosexual fans of
Pat Forde I just don't know if I can
marry this caller you know I don't think
I can Gary someone for you don't even
know
you don't even know okay so anyway
people very very excited about Pat's
birthday and it was an incredible
birthday weekend I'm sure and people
loving it people loving it so that's
that congratulations to Pat and I don't
know for what I mean he's congratulate
23 years I publish made alive for an
additional year and we're all grateful
for that on the bonus show today hard to
transition out of that and I struggled
but I think I've transitioned out on the
bonus show half of America is in poverty
I'll explain what I mean by that
Kellyanne Conway is saying that some of
the criticism of her is gender based an
interesting argument for Kellyanne
Conway to make and also the Air Force
wants permission to shoot down civilian
drones what is that all about why do
they want that right and is it a good
idea all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show you can sign up and
get instant access to the bonus show
it's a whole other show if you like this
show why not get the bonus show it's
more show you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership coupon code
is I voted 17 and remember pledges of as
little as a dollar a month where can you
do on patreon.com slash david packard
show we will speak to you on the bonus
show
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]